et ministre des affaires étrangères du
luxembourg et de la fédération de russie
bonjour nous avons des discussions tout
à fait intéressante et qui selon la
tradition
on était dans une atmosphère de
confiance et pour cette septième
septième visite de monsieur jean
asselborn
en russie les liens entre nos deux pays
les liens sont anciens et nous fêtons
cette année les 85e le 85ème
anniversaire de l'établissement de
relations diplomatiques et en 2020 ce
sera le 130e année le 131e le 130e
anniversaire de l'établissement des
relations diplomatiques entre le
luxembourg et l empire russe contenu des
accords qui ont été conclus par nos
autorités ces derniers temps nous avons
accordé une grande importance aux
aspects économiques et commerciaux de
nos échanges sur les questions
d'investissement et d'investissement
notamment en matière industrielle
sur le plan des produits financiers
aussi est aussi ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les finances verte nous
avons aussi attiré notre attention sur
les questions liées à l espace des deux
côtés nous avons apprécié les travaux
menés par la commission
russo belgo luxembourgeoise de
coopération financière économique avec
le luxembourg les liens parlementaires
sont entretenus c'est à dire qu'il ya eu
des échanges qui ont été consacrés par
la création l'année dernière de groupes
d'amitiés parlementaires et les régions
russes ont aussi un intérêt avec le
grand duché de luxembourg et donc nous
allons travailler pour suivre ceux se
ses liens au niveau régional nous
travaillons également le salon si la
participation de luxembourg la aux
tournées culturelle des saisons russes
dans le monde est là monsieur le premier
le monsieur le ministre a dit que le
grand duché du luxembourg accepté
l'invitation du président poutine a
participé au défilé militaire du 9 mai
prochain en l'honneur de la victoire à
la fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale
nous saluons aussi l'initiative du
luxembourg de diriger un monument à la
mémoire des
russes qui ont été engagés dans des
travaux forcés à la pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale sur le territoire du
luxembourg nous savons que le luxembourg
est un partenaire actif de l'union
européenne nous savons que il se
prononce pour que les relations entre la
russie et l'union européenne revienne à
un dialogue constructif
de notre côté nous allons manifester
notre préoccupation face à
l'augmentation du potentiel militaire de
l'otan d'autant plus qu'on voit le
développement déploiement des armes de
l'otan dépasser largement les nécessités
qui devrait s'imposer à cela nous avons
certain nombre de propositions concrètes
à avancer notamment matière de
construction de la sécurité stratégique
et de l' architecture de sécurité sur le
continent européen et on sait qu'un
certain nombre de déclarations ont été
faites sur ce plan mais pour l'instant
nous n'avons pas encore vu deux mesures
concrètes
de notre côté nous allons proposer à
l'otan de procéder à une désescalade
détention et nous attendons des réponses
avec le sobre nous avons aussi d'autres
questions à l'ordre du jour qui concerne
l'actualité politique internationale au
moyen-orient dans le nord de l'afrique
en syrie en libye et dans ce cas comme
dans l'autre
comme dans tout contact régional la
russie se prononce pour la mise en place
de dialogue inclusif politique générale
avec toutes les parties impliquées pour
le respect de la souveraineté et
l'intégrité territoriale des pays d état
et qu'il n'y a aucun compromis possible
avec les les terroristes qui se sont
développées après la crise du printemps
arabe de 2011 la russie comme le
luxembourg et de même que l'union
européenne dans son ensemble sont
préoccupés autour de la situation du
conflit du règlement du conflit israélo
palestinien et nous avons rappelé la
nécessité de trouver une solution
politique via un dialogue direct entre
israéliens et palestiniens sur la base
des décisions qui ont été déjà adoptée
par l'onu ainsi que sur la base de
l'initiative de paix arabe qui dans le
cadre du règlement israélo-palestinien
propose une pacification totale des
relations entre les palestiniens et les
israéliens
nous avons traité également de ce qui se
produit aujourd'hui en ukraine et nous
avons rappelé encore une fois la
nécessité de s'en tenir aux accords 2000
sq et des accords qui ont été conclus
dans le cadre du format normandie de
façon à abaisser les tensions sur le
terrain et encore une fois je
je rappelle qu'il est nécessaire de
procéder à un dialogue direct avec les
républiques de donetsk de lougansk dans
le strict respect de désaccord 2006
puisque cela figurait dans les
conditions
accor de minsk encore une fois cette
réunion que nous avons eue a été très
positive nous allons poursuivre les
échanges réguliers avec nos collègues du
luxembourg et je remercie jean asselborn
pour ces discussions tout à fait utile
[Musique]
que je suis ici donc en tant que
ministre à moscou la première fois
c'était en 2005 et je suis très content
donc tu avoir été invité après trois ans
je n'étais pas ici pour nous entretenir
façon amicale
évidemment en ce qui concerne le
luxembourg il n'y a pas de problèmes
insurmontables
en ce qui concerne les relations
bilatérales série lavrov a très bien
résumé je n'ai pas besoin de rappeler ce
que je voudrais quand même dire c'est
que nous aurons maintenant au mois de
premier semestre cette réunion entre lui
et bl et la russie à luxembourg nous
nous réjouissons et je pense que en ce
qui concerne nos relations économiques
nos relations commerciales
nous devons faire fi aux différents
problèmes qui existent mais évidemment
n'avons jamais couper ses relations avec
la russie et la russie même après 2014
parce que nous pensons que à travers
donc le commerce et aussi donc
l'économie
on pourra revenir à une situation
beaucoup plus favorable à nouveau entre
la relation donc bilatérales entre le
luxembourg et et la russie mais aussi au
niveau européen ne devons pas oublier
que le luxembourg est un pays fondateur
de l'union européenne un pays à mon avis
qui a toujours cherché à défendre
l'idée d'une institution européenne donc
européenne pas seulement pour son propre
pays et je pense que il faut le répéter
l'union européenne et la russie sont
deux voisines
les deux voisines doivent se parler et
doivent tout faire pour que en
diplomatie
on puisse résoudre les problèmes qui
existent alors n'oublions pas aussi que
en ce qui concerne par exemple les visas
schengen ce sont les demandes russe en
nombre et qui sont très très importante
ce sont les plus importants des pays
dans schengen nous avons aussi erasme eu
plus il ya un grand nombre d'étudiants
russe qui demande donc d'être intrigue
est intégré dans ce système et vice
versa aussi beaucoup de d'étudiants
européens qui veulent et qui viennent en
russie donc c'est entre les peuples
aussi l'union européenne joue quand même
un rôle très important
alors maintenant en ce qui concerne les
grands problèmes sur la planète
nous allons discuter certainement nous
avons commencé à discuter de la syrie
je pense que c'est un moment crucial
pour la syrie c'est pas l'europe mais
ces nations unies qui disent qu'il y a
neuf cent mille personnes déplacées dont
cinq cent mille enfants dans des
conditions horribles parfois et je pense
que l'art ici on est très conscient et
que la russie a quand même un rôle
capital à jouer et le joue aussi je
l'espère dont les prochains jours pour
stopper cette crise humanitaire
deuxièmement je pense que nous devons
parler aussi de l'ukraine
évidemment personne n'est content avec
les sanctions
d'un côté comme de l'autre et nous
espérons en tant que gouvernement
luxembourgeois que après la réunion de
paris
il y est maintenant la prochaine réunion
qui est prévue à berlin il ya des
progrès l'intégrité du territoire de
l'ukraine c'est clair mais aussi arrêter
la guerre dont le donbass est une chose
très importante
alors je les dis la russie elle est
membre du pefa et la russie est un
incontournable pour la sécurité en
europe
je pense que sur cette base là il faut
que nous ayons le courage des deux côtés
de huy de définir une politique qui soit
à nouveau une politique en des termes
plus longs mots je pense aussi que en ce
qui concerne les droits de l'homme et
celle et lavrov
l'adie la russie n'est pas contre la
reprise du dialogue entre l'union
européenne et la russie je pense même
que il ya une possibilité de faire venir
le représentant donc pour les droits de
l'homme de l'union européenne iman c'est
un le ministre des affaires étrangères
de l'irlande dire mort dont ils veulent
gilmore qui pourraient être acceptés en
récit pour en parler et je pense aussi
que faut savoir que l'union européenne a
fait beaucoup d'efforts pour que la
russie soit à nouveau à membres intégral
du conseil de l'europe
c'est très bien je pense qu'être membre
du conseil de l'europe et défendre les
droits humains et la wii c'est ça va
ensemble ça ne peut pas être séparés en
ce qui concerne les commémorations je
suis très content de pouvoir dire que
notre grand duc henri va venir a donc le
9 mai à moscou
mon pays sera donc représenté au plus
haut niveau
et puis la grande leçon je pense que ce
75e anniversaire doit être que c'est de
notre responsabilité collectif donc
d'être unis pour la paix nous devons
entendre ce qui nous est enseignée non
seulement de vie voire encore cette
année par les vétérans qui sont encore
parmi nous mais aussi par le silence
assourdissant des cimetières militaires
qui jalonnent les paysages de notre
continent et donc je remercie donc la
russie d'avoir organisé cette festivité
très importante qui doit être une
festivité des festivités pour la paix
pour terminer peut-être encore de deux
remarques
la première c'est ce que la voix fier de
mentionner israël palestine
donc moi je pense que nous aurons un
débat dans l'union européenne
je pense que tout plan qui est donc mis
sur la table qu'il soit un plomb du
siècle ou pas du siècle c'est pas
tellement important mais où il faut
quand même signaler clairement que les
colonies en palestine donc sont de la
responsabilité israélienne du
gouvernement israélien ne peuvent pas
être légaux une toute en actions aussi à
venir ne peut pas être
conforme au droit international et donc
je ne connais pas l'alternative à la
solution à deux états il faut quand même
dire que israël à un état et si on parle
continue à parler d'une solution à deux
états il faut que les palestiniens aient
la chance de vivre aussi dans un état et
que cet état physiquement doit exister
l'otan et la russie très important je
pense que je me rappelle toujours après
des conflits et après par exemple 2009
le ministre des affaires étrangères de
l'allemagne qui est maintenant président
allemand au frankfurter times toujours
dit il faut même s'il ya des crises
maintenir le conseil entre l'otan et la
russie c'est important il ya des
contacts au niveau militaire il ya des
difficultés encore de réunir ses
conseils mais je pense que des deux
côtés il ne faut pas faut pas abandonner
il faut préparer la piste ce conseil qui
serait très important surtout si on voit
sûr que cette année sera une année
décisive pour tous les traités qui
concerne le désarmement
merci madame monsieur passe aux
questions à jean ce spectacle a quitté
valence de presse hispanique qui a
déclaré hier que qu'elle va ouvrir ses
frontières
et qu'elle n'appellera pas le passage
des réfugiés syriens en europe et aussi
la situation en syrie avaient être
abordée lors du sommet extraordinaire de
le tarn et la turquie aujourd'hui donc
première question comment évaluez-vous
les commentaires fort faites par les
côtés sur quatre rapports la russie est
deuxième question est ce que cette
décision sur les réfugiés était une
surprise pour l'euro est ce que l'europe
est prête pour cette possibilité de la
nouvelle crise migratoire
merci beaucoup s'il veut répondre
spontanément à la dernière question je
dis non mais c'est un peu plus compliqué
je n'ai pas eu de confirmation d'après
mes informations que ce que le porte
parole turc a dit est confirmée je pense
que d'abord il faut que cesse cette
situation qui est une situation très
difficile pour des dizaines de milliers
de familles ils vouvoyaient les images
de la télévision qui doit fuir le
territoire de dealip dans des conditions
affreuses dans le froid et ils ne savent
pas où aller
donc effectivement s'ils veulent quitter
la syrie c'est ça leur leurs projets il
ya qu un pays qui est voisin c'est la
turquie et donc je pense que c'est
surtout un problème à mon avis qui est
un problème qui dépasse un peu la
question de la migration
la problème comment est ce qu on peut
éviter cet exode de masse
comment est-ce qu'on peut éviter qu avec
tes bons des bombes et des armes
on sait à résoudre le problème je sais
qu'il y à quelques milliers de
djihadistes
hyde l'ip mais il ya aussi des millions
de gens comme nous d'aider des gens qui
vivent très difficilement dans cette
ville et qu'on ne va pas résoudre à mon
avis le problème avec des bombes et avec
des missiles et donc pour cela
je pense qu'il faut une coopération au
niveau des pays qui sont engagés je les
dis la russie est un pays qui a une
énorme influence en syrie la turquie
c'est assez complexe à comprendre ce qui
se passe je rappelle ce qui a été décidé
à sotchi en 2018
c'était autre chose que aujourd'hui donc
pour répondre à votre question c'est pas
parle pas la migration qu'il faut donc
approcher ce problème mais c'est d'abord
comment et qu'est ce qui peut être fait
pour que ces exodes cet exode soit
stoppée je voudrais ajouter demande et
soutenir ce que vient de dire monsieur
jean ce band c'est à dire que tous les
acteurs impliqués doivent faire un
effort de coopération pour assurer une
désescalade de la situation et pour
éviter toute situation de crise et c'est
bien notre objectif dans nos discussions
avec nos partenaires de l'union
européenne de l'otan et
les etats unis c'est bien à pau c'est
important de comprendre la nécessité de
cette coopération et qu'elle se
manifeste à tous les points de vue en
2003 nous avions nous avions refusé de
coopérer avec les américains et les
anglais alors dans leurs intentions
intentions de bombarder l'iran sur des
prétextes absolument sur des détenus des
prétextes absolument fallacieux ensuite
sans avoir consulté quoi qui que ce soit
et en infraction aux décisions du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu les alliés
de l'otan avaient bombardé la libye en
2011 et nous apprécions les efforts qui
sont faits par nos partenaires la france
l'allemagne l'italie et d'autres pays
pour apaiser la situation
mais soyons honnêtes les uns avec les
autres nous soyons clairs c'est très
difficile de restaurer l'unité de ce
pays
mais ce que je veux dire c'est en
soutenant l'appel lancé par monsieur
jean haas banda à coopérer je dis oui il
faut coopérer à toutes les étapes
d'examen de telle ou telle rien et si
possible avant que un problème devienne
une catastrophe et que des habitants de
tir hague de l'hymne de libye de syrie
se retrouve dans cette situation et nos
partenaires occidentaux ici doivent s'en
tenir au principe du respect des
intérêts de toutes les parties qui sont
impliqués de telle ou telle façon dans
ces crises et en général les intérêts
géopolitiques de
se résume souvent à la restriction de
désintérêt de la russie de la chine
c'est souvent ça que serait que se
résume souvent la stratégie occidentale
or souvent cela ne concordent pas avec
la nécessité de ce qu'il faut faire pour
mettre fin aux souffrances des peuples
de concernés et notre intention a
toujours été connue de nos partenaires
occidentaux alors allons-y mettons nous
d'accord pour que chacun de ces pays
puissent vivre dans la paix la sécurité
la stabilité et mettons fin à toutes ces
méthodes néo coloniale ou purement
coloniale dans cette région du monde
question de la chaîne russia tonneau
stauder bonjour monsieur le ministre
pour poursuivre le thème la situation à
idleb et s'est sérieusement aggravé ces
derniers temps on l'armée syrienne est
présenté comme invités comme cible par
l'armée turque en voix 33 militaires
turcs ont été tués
les médias turcs accuse la suite la
russie et il ya des consultations qui
devraient être entreprises par la
turquie avec l'otan alors quid du format
1 stana que va-t-il en autre question
ces jours ci le vice-président américain
mike pence a déclaré ce qui suit c'est
la liberté pas le socialisme qui a mis
fin à l' esclavage qui a gagné de guerre
et fait des états unis d'amérique un
espoir pour toute l'humanité
en fait
pour résumer dans les faits ça veut dire
qu'ils excluent l'urss 2 de la liste des
pays vainqueur à la deuxième guerre
mondiale et compte tenu du fait que la
russie ne cesse de rappeler la nécessité
d'éviter les falsifications dans
l'histoire et qu elle rappelle son
groupe le rôle majeur de l'urss dans la
victoire nazie alors la première
question sur idleb ce qui se passe
notamment avec la participation deux
militaires de la turquie nous rappelons
encore une fois que nous sommes attachés
aux accords qui était qui ont été
conclus entre le président turc et le
président de la fédération de russie
pour procéder la désescalade dans la
zone de conflit de d'idleb et
démilitarisé
cette zone pour que personne ne puisse
bombarder les bases militaires syriennes
russe et que les routes qui sont sur
place puisse être sûr ce sont les
objectifs que nous avons fixés
le problème chez nous c'est qu'il faut
commencer à respecter les engagements
pris et pendant un an et demi nous avons
constaté que
pas grand chose n'a été fait et que
l'armée syrienne a tout à fait le droit
de d'éliminer les terroristes et ici on
ne peut pas interdire à l'armée
syriennes de respecter ses engagements
qui ont été entérinés par la résolution
du conseil de sécurité de l'onu d'autres
lieux l'incident est aujourd'hui le
ministère de la défense de la fédération
de russie a fait une déclaration
détaillée confirmant que les militaires
russes et turcs sur le terrain sont en
contact permanent et étroit notamment en
matière de de mise en place de postes
d'observation si je me trompe pas ces 12
sur zone et que les polices militaire
sur place
informe notre centre pour la
réconciliation des parties belligérantes
sur la localisation des militaires
russes dans la zone de désescalade
d'idlib et à quel moment donc les
coordonnées sont transmises aux forces
armées pour que pour éviter tout
problème est que assurer la sécurité des
déplacements des militaires tués donc
les coordonnées qui ont été transmises
hier ne contiennent pas les
délocalisations ou dans la pratique en
fait se trouvaient des militaires russes
et aussi des formations terroristes
armés dès que
dès l'obtention de ces informations la
nôtre meister de la défense fait une
déclaration et prend l'ensemble des
mesures nécessaires pour assurer la
sécurité de l'évacuation des blessés et
le transfert des militaires des corps
des militaires qui ont été tuées encore
une fois la question n'est pas de savoir
si une partie un plan qui contredit
l'accord conclu sur la zone de
désescalade d'idleb c'est comment dans
la pratique
cet accord est mise en oeuvre c'est à
dire que c'est ce ce processus de dé
confection qui a été souvent souvent
évoquée dans l'est de la syrie et dans
la zone de désescalade d'escaladé dlep
encore une fois il ait eu un accord qui
a été conclu il faut voir comment il est
respecté et est ce que les localisations
de militaires sont transmises de façon
correcte et ses tragédies
bien entendu aurait pu être évité et
nous présentons nos condoléances
et encore une fois nous faisons notre
maximum pour que la sécurité des
militaires russes qui participent au
régime de désescalade dans la région le
dilemme pour qu'elles soient ses assurés
et que ces missions se poursuivre vous
avez évoqué le demande
de consultations entre la turquie et
l'otan et je pense que c'est le droit de
tout membre de l'alliance atlantique en
matière de régulation des relations
entre les pays ils ont cette possibilité
de demander des consultations en cas de
menace ou de deux de risque pour ça pour
son indépendance pour sa souveraineté
territoriale etc et notamment si un
membre de l'otan et fait l'objet d'une
agression à ce moment là effectivement
il ya ce mécanisme de consultation et je
ne pense pas que ne ce qui s'est passé
en syrie où bhl a fait l'objet de telles
consultations en tout cas en conformité
avec l'accord de washington qui avait
scellé ces dispositions au sein de
l'alliance et qui prévoit donc des
mesures de réponse en cas d'agression en
ce qui concerne le sort des formats
d'astana et le dialogue il ya toujours
un espace de dialogue ça c'est clair
entre les présidents poutine et erdogan
un dialogue s'est tenue cet entretien a
été détaillée et encore une fois nous
faisons le maximum pour respecter les
accords qui avaient été précédemment
conclus sur la zone de désescalade
le délai très prochainement nous aurons
la possibilité de d'établir des contacts
à des degrés divers mais d'ailleurs et
il ya une heure et demie nous avons été
informés que les négociations les
négociateurs turquie et élira à ankara
sont prêts à poursuivre les délais sont
donc je pense pas qu'il y ait de
problème absolument insurmontable en ce
qui concerne le format d'astana et non
le ministère de la défense travaille là
dessus en se référant aux accords
concernant la zone de désescalade
d'élèves
encore une fois il s'agit de
l'application de ce camp vous avez vous
m'avez interrogé à propos de la
déclaration de mike pence le vice
président américain
c'est à dire sur la question de savoir
comment
quels sont les processus dans le monde
aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui apporte le bienvenu à
l'humanité ce n'est pas la première fois
que monsieur peines manifeste
s'exprime de façon un peu méprisante
vis-à-vis de l'histoire le 23 janvier
dernier à à jérusalem à l'inauguration
du monument aux victimes de l'holocauste
il avait hésité et et évoquer les
horreurs commises par les nazis sur le
peuple juif en à propos de john
d'auschwitz il avait dit que les soldats
étaient effarés de voir les horreurs
dans un commises dans ce camp et et il
ya eu un un murmure dans la salle c'est
à dire que quelqu'un a demandé mais des
soldats de quelle armée mais d'autant
plus que le président israélien rivlin
le pré le premier ministre netanyahu le
président français macron tous les uns
tous les intervenants avaient rappelé le
rôle de l'armée rouge et du peuple
soviétique dans la victoire sur le
nazisme est mal quel pin savez est
négligée d'évoquer ce point là après
s'il dit que la liberté a mis fin à
l'esclavagé oui c'est vrai mais le scav
âge a existé pendant plusieurs chèques
mais il a été complètement et éliminer
que dans la deuxième moitié du xxème
siècle dans les années 60 si je me
trompe pas ah oui qui avait été lui
aussi
oui et que la liberté a gagné deux
guerres et a fait des états unis un
espoir pour toute l'humanité
c'est ce qu'il a dit à en juger par la
d'après l'attitude des etats-unis dans
le monde
c'est peut-être un projecteur de ce
train de ceux du phare de ce train qui
écrase tout donc si c'est une
déclaration de monsieur pence je pense
que surtout l'année de l'anniversaire de
la victoire sur le nazisme de cette
victoire dans laquelle les alliés ont
apporté une contribution majeure et de
l'année de l'anniversaire de la création
de l'onu
je pense qu'il devrait éviter de faire
des commentaires
méprisant et hautain mais plutôt se
concentrer sur l'universel et et des
menaces qui s'accumulent et sur la
nécessité de mener un dialogue pour
retrouver l'équilibré des intérêts et je
penche le sait c'est un dialogue qui v
c'est ce dialogue auquel appellent le
président poutine en invitant les prési
les représentants des cinq pays membres
non permanents du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu je pense que membre de l'otan et
l'otan est maintenant en réunion à
bruxelles
peut-être deux trois phrases je crois
que tout le monde est triste si des
soldats à perte leur vie nous sommes
évidemment aussi très triste de toutes
les personnes civils en syrie qui ont
perdu leur vie
il faut quand même rappeler serré il a
parlé de l'article iv et de l'article 5
que la turquie n'a pas demandé
l'autorisation à l'otan pour cette
opération militaire en syrie
donc maintenant elle est tout à fait
dans son droit de demander assistance
donc sur bast l'article 4 mais de grâce
on n'est pas à l'article 5
parce que qu'est ce que cela
signifierait c'est que
des troupes de l'otan donc serait
impliqué en syrie contre le gouvernement
syrien qu'on vous le voulez avec tout ce
que cela impliquerait on n'est pas là et
je n'espère pas qu'on arrive on y
arrivera j'espère que pour l'instant ses
dialogues entre le président pauthe il
est président erdogan sera un dialogue
qui mène à une solution
je crois que la russie je suis
convaincue elle fera tout pour que ce
cette opération militaire cet engagement
militaire stopper donc c'est pas mon
avis la seule solution possible tout ce
qui se rapporte maintenant à l'otan
c'est pas l'otan qui va donc résoudre ce
problème
j'oserais ajoute encore une chose d je
suis très reconnaissant à jeun seule
borne de rappeler ces points importants
avec son autorité il ya un autre aspect
que je voudrais encore une fois évoqué
nous en avons parlé ce qui est important
c'est de ne pas perdre de vue dans cette
situation à idleb de perdre de vue quels
sont les objectifs de chacune des
parties
monsieur jefferies représentants des
états unis pour la syrie a déclaré déjà
plusieurs fois que fait attal cham qui
est une résurgence de diabaté nous sera
et qui est enregistré comme organisation
de téléphone terroriste par le conseil
de sécurité de l'onu elle se débarrasse
d'eux
ces extrémistes de ces éléments inutiles
et devient une partie de prenante du
processus de régulation est comme ça a
été dit une force qui s'opposent au
gouvernement d'assad au régime d'assad
comme nos collègues occidentaux disent
cette appréciation donné et qui avaient
déjà été analysés par les politologues
ou aux états unis et dans les pays
occidentaux au sein des organisations
notamment basée en grande bretagne ont
donné un commentaire récent né ce groupe
de crise
ce groupe international d'étude des
crises disait que monsieur jack qui est
à la tête de ceux de cette organisation
taurus qui a activement développer les
idées de monsieur jefferies a dit que
cette organisation terroriste se
transforme et que son objectif n'est
plus de faire des attentats mais de
renverser le régime n'est les
commentaires donnés en occident en en
occident sont de plus en plus tourné
dans ce sens-là de la façon la plus
heureuse je voudrais mettre en garde nos
collègues occidentaux contre toute
répétition des mêmes erreurs passées ou
dans
selon laquelle le renversement d'un d'un
gouvernement que ce soit en syrie en
libye ou d'autres pays
dans cet intérêt on s'appuie sur des
alliés terroristes et en espérant
utiliser des terroristes dans des
objectifs géopolitiques pour pouvoir les
utiliser
je vous rappelle que ça s'est jamais
passé dans l'histoire et qu' il n'est
pas possible de discuter avec les
terroristes on ne peut pas miser dans
des objectifs pareil sur de telles
personnes fin de la conférence de presse
je vous remercie
qui